on essaie de canaliser l'angoisse pour
être toujours dans une énergie
productive lui il a besoin aussi qu'on
lui prend le nourrisse d'une énergie
productive on n'est pas endémie du fait
qu'il a il y a quand même un risque
important qui soit exécuté dans 10 jours
en même temps ça ne l'empêche pas de
faire des projets d'avenir
Sandrine à Georges Skinner
dans le mari et dans un couloir de la
mort au Texas et doit être exécuté le 9
novembre dans 10 jours
[Musique]
Sandrine agence qui ne rebondoire
j'étais le 15 décembre 1960 à Joigny
dans l'Yonne père médecin de campagne
mère assistante dentaire vous grandissez
dans une petite maison bourguignonne au
rythme tranquille de la vie loin des
villes mais très tôt une lame de fond va
naître en vous la passion de la
politique
vous avez 15 ans lorsque vos parents se
séparent vous suivez votre mère à Paris
et ce bouleversement ne fait qu'eguiser
votre intérêt pour les causes politiques
le 28 juillet 1976 Christian Ranucci
condamné à mort pour meurtre d'une
fillette de 8 ans est exécutée vous
dites je m'en souviens très bien je ne
cherchais pas à savoir s'il était
coupable ou pas ce qui m'a choqué c'est
qu'on le découpe en deux et je me suis
dit mais c'est pas possible qu'en France
aujourd'hui enfin c'est en 1976 on coupe
des gens en deux au nom de la justice ça
me paraissait pas supportable
après un passage à Marseille chez votre
père quand votre mère tombe malade vous
remontez à Paris pour faire une licence
d'anglais vous partez à Londres vous
devenez assistante de production puis
directrice de production de films
publicitaires et de films de cinéma vous
gagnez bien votre vie à l'époque
mais parallèlement vous cherchez à vous
impliquer dans ce qui deviendra le
combat de votre vie la lutte contre la
peine de mort vous vous rapprochez
d'amnistie international vous devenez
coordinatrice pour le Rwanda et le
Burundi ouais en Angleterre
en 1981 François Mitterrand abolit la
peine de mort donc ça vous encourage
bien sûr c'était très tardif la France
était le 35e pays au monde à abolir on
était le dernier Europe occidentale donc
il y a pas trop de quoi être fier donc
on était quand même très content que ça
se passe enfin après six ans à Londres
vous rentrez à Paris où vous continuez
votre job de Directrice de Production
vous faites un enfant Daphné
quelques années plus tard en 1995 un ami
vous suggère de lire un article dans
Télérama consacré à une association de
condamnés à mort au Texas qui s'appelle
la lampe de l'espoir et dont le principe
est de correspondre avec des prisonniers
enfermés dans le couloir de la mort aux
USA pour les aider à garder un lien avec
le monde extérieur oui cette association
elle était unique parce qu'elle a été
créée par les condamnés à morts du Texas
et elle était gérée de l'intérieur du
couloir de la mort vous entamez une
relation épistolaire avec trois détenus
dont hanskiner dans la première lettre
vous présentez sans plus et lui vous
répond 30 pages
oui mais pour lui trempage c'est pas
énorme
même encore aujourd'hui j'ai reçu deux
lettres une jeudi 36 pages une vendredi
32 pages c'est beaucoup moins que ce
qu'il a créé une période mais il est
très fatigué donc il écrit moins on va
dire il vous raconte sa vie quotidienne
parle de son enfant
de sa vie de ce qui de ce qui est puis
ensuite effectivement ce qu'il vit dans
le couloir des difficultés des
conditions de détention quand on est un
blanc et qu'on soutient les condamnés à
mort des minorités raciales qu'on les
défend qu'on les assiste et qu'on se
fait saquer par des gardiens et
maltraités par des gardiens qui sont du
Ku Klux Klan et il en a beaucoup
souffert il a passé beaucoup beaucoup de
temps au mitard à cause de ça en lisant
cette lettre évidemment le trouble
s'installe en vous vous dites c'est mon
double quoi et même goût musicaux les
mêmes goût littéraires les mêmes
références politiques donc c'est un choc
pour vous j'imagine ouais surtout qu'on
vient vraiment de deux planètes
différentes
alors oui si votre double certes mais
avec une histoire personnelle totalement
opposée à la vôtre lui il était rebelle
à 14 ans il quitte le foyer familial
pour suivre la tournée de Led Zeppelin
aux USA et vous êtes fan de LED
il a connu l'alcool les drogues et puis
il a commis des menus larçants
quand même il a travaillé avec des
grands avocats pénalistes
on part tracer son cas ici mais disons
qu'il est accusé du meurtre de sa petite
amie et des deux fils de cette femme
enfin il y a de nombreux points non
élucinés dans son affaire clairement il
y a des éléments franches à des charges
qui n'ont jamais été présentés ni au
procès que les tribunaux ne veulent pas
accepter en appel et on a toujours 95%
des scellés de la scène de crime qui ne
sont pas testés alors d'aujourd'hui en
2000 après 5 ans de relation
épistolaires vous vous rendez pour la
première fois dans la prison de
paulinsky et là vous découvrez ANK à
travers une épaisse vitre en plexiglas
vous sentez que des sentiments amoureux
sont en train de mettre à ce moment-là
je pense qu'ils étaient déjà là avant
d'ailleurs
mais on s'en parle pas encore à ce
moment-là c'est on est tous les deux
très pudiques de ça d'abord parce que
lui ne voulait pas m'entraîner dans son
monde en enfer dans le couloir moi je me
disais que c'était peut-être une vue de
l'esprit et que il fallait qu'on appr à
se connaître et voir si réellement il se
passait quelque chose alors les années
suivantes vous y allez quatre fois par
an entre 4 et 8 semaines à chaque fois
et vous avez droit à une visite par
semaine
quelle est
quand on aime on ne compte pas
alors quand vous voyez vous collez
chacun les mains sur la vitre en
plexiglas
jusqu'à un moment il vous dit bon arrête
c'est horrible quoi ah oui parce que on
le fait presque instinctivement et puis
si on laisse nos mains comme ça très
vite on se rend compte qu'on n'a pas il
y a pas de il y a pas touché on a une
sensation visuelle et on se rend compte
que c'est horrible la frustration est
terrible vous dites en plus je crois pas
du tout aux amours platoniques
et puis un jour en 2008 vous recevez une
lettre de 30 pages où il vous dit il
faut qu'on se marie tu lui dis mais
qu'est-ce qui t'arrive là ça te prend
comme une envie de pisser d'un seul coup
non mais il y a une urgence il y a une
raison est-ce que tu as perdu tes appels
tu me l'as pas dit et quand je l'ai vu
il m'a dit non non pas du tout mais
c'est maintenant
alors là bon c'est un mariage par
procuration lui évidemment on peut pas
venir donc c'est votre copine Nancy qui
vient j'ai l'impression de vous marier
avec votre copine quoi ah oui c'était
c'était particulier est-ce que vous avez
épousé un homme ou une cause ah non j'ai
posé un homme clairement
au fil des lettres vous découvrez ce
qu'est le couloir de la mort
c'est-à-dire une cellule de 2 m sur 3
avec une toute petite fenêtre mais pour
accéder à cette fenêtre il faut monter
sur le lit et se mettre sur la pointe
des pieds quoi c'est elle est
horizontale c'est une fenêtre qui ne
s'ouvre pas d'ailleurs de toute façon
donc s'il y a un bloc de détention en
face il voit du béton et si c'est le
dernier bloc et ben ils ont la chance de
voir de la nature donc le mec a
construit ça il le savait ça ah mais
vous savez que les architectes qui
construisent les prisons de sécurité
sont très très fiers il faudrait les
faire vivre dedans d'ailleurs les
dernières qui ont été construites c'est
mais c'est le summum de l'horreur
c'est-à-dire que les cellules sont
placées telles façon que le prisonnier
ne peut même pas voir ce qui se passe
devant la porte de sa cellule on les
complètement tout est automatisé
à l'extérieur quand on va se promener
c'est dans une cellule qui est un petit
peu plus grande que celle où on est et
ça s'arrête là une fois par semaine ils
sont censés aller dans une cour
extérieure et toute petite on peut même
pas faire le tour en courant tellement
c'est ridiculement petit courant béton
très très grillagé on a du mal à voir le
ciel donc mais toujours seul ils sont à
l'isolement total alors le seul contact
qu'on a avec un autre être humain en
fait c'est quand les gardiens vous
tapent dessus quoi oui ou quand il vous
passe les menottes ou quand vous allez
au service médical et que le médecin va
vous examiner en plus les gardiens sont
assez sadiques ils empêchent les détenus
de dormir en les réveillant toutes les
45 minutes c'est leur parano sécuritaire
qui fait que surtout quand ils sont dans
le bloc de tous ceux qui ont des dates
d'exécution parce qu'on a tellement peur
qu'ils suscitent avant d'être exécuté ce
serait tellement dommage que du coup on
les réveille
sans ouverture sans même en restriction
de nourriture c'est à dire qu'on
récupère tous les restes des repas et on
mélange avec de la farine on leur fait
un pain et leur fil un pain pour 15
jours et je débrouille avec ça inhume ah
oui non mais c'est le goulag hein
américaine il faut quand même en parler
un jour sérieusement parce que c'est il
y a des mineurs qui vivent dans des
conditions pareilles aussi aux
États-Unis il faut quand même pas
l'oublier en juin 2008 vous apprenez que
vous êtes privé du droit de visite et du
droit de correspondance c'est un moyen
de faire pression sur lui en fait on est
dans un truc complètement cascaïen de
gens qui sont au-dessus de la loi et qui
c'est le Far West voilà c'est tout il
faut quand même se souvenir que c'est un
pays qui s'est construit sur la violence
mais qui surtout qui a une culture du
châtiment qui est incroyable le rapport
à la vengeance la confusion entre la
vengeance et la justice et absolument
dramatique et a des conséquences
dramatiques encore aujourd'hui
échappe à l'exécution en 1999 mais en
2009 vous apprenez que son exécution est
fixée au 24 février 2010 voilà c'est le
compte à rebours qui commence on savait
qu'il y avait un vice de forme sur le
mandat d'exécution donc on savait qu'il
y aura un report mais on ne pensait pas
que ce report serait pour 30 jours plus
tard et donc on a une nouvelle date pour
le 24 mars vous dites quand la date
arrive je perds la notion du temps
ça me déstabilise c'est que je
verrouille en moi le calendrier c'est à
dire que je sais que si je dois pouvoir
gérer le reste au quotidien je peux pas
commencer à compter les jours c'est pas
possible et d'ailleurs malheureusement
je n'ai toujours pas depuis un an et
demi maintenant toujours pas retrouvé
mon sens du calendrier alors l'exécution
est donc repoussée d'un mois en clair ça
veut dire que son agonie va durer 30
jours de plus
dans un dernier courrier
Hank vous suggère de faire la fête il
vous dit le jour où j'y passerai tout
sera fini buvez un coup et fumer un
joint en mémoire de moi
une demi-heure avant l'exécution en a
déjà quitté la cellule quand la Cour
suprême accorde un sursis jusqu'au 9
novembre 2011 c'est-à-dire dans 10 jours
de maintenant
illimité elle a mis deux mois pour
décider d'accepter ou pas son dossier
donc on a eu deux mois toutes les
semaines aussi c'était l'angoisse parce
que si elle avait refusé il reprenait
une date pour 30 jours plus tard donc
effectivement il y a une audience en
2010 on a gagné en mars cette année et
malgré sa jurisprudence majeure le juge
qui là condamné à mort a resigner un
mandat d'exécution pour le 9 novembre
cette année oui
dans 10 jours dans 10 jours dans ces
cas-là vous fumez beaucoup j'imagine
beaucoup trop
ça vous détruit psychologiquement on
essaye de on essaie de canaliser
l'angoisse pour être toujours dans une
énergie productive lui il a besoin aussi
qu'on lui prend le nourrisse une énergie
productive on n'est pas en déni du fait
qu'il a il y a quand même un risque
important qui soit exécuté dans 10 jours
en même temps ça ne l'empêche pas de
faire des projets d'avenir les voyages
qu'il a envie de faire de ce qu'il a
envie de voir en Europe notre toute
dernière visite le 24 mars l'année
dernière il faisait encore des projets
alors effectivement ce qui est terrible
dans cette histoire c'est que la seule
fois où vous risquez
de toucher et d'embrasser votre mari ça
sera la morgue oui les corps sont
transférés très vite après les
exécutions justement pour que les
familles puissent enfin avoir un contact
avec un corps chaud c'est absolument
sordide et c'est comme ça si regardez la
télé
c'est que je suis extrêmement fier de
lui qu'il a une force de survie
exceptionnelle que que je sais pourquoi
je l'aime et je sais que quoi qu'il
arrive je serai avec lui
alors je vous l'ai signaler que Hank et
vous faites l'objet d'un documentaire
diffusé sur Canal+ le 8 novembre à 22h20
qui s'appelle un moment dans la vie de
hand spinner c'est formidable je l'ai vu
ce documentaire j'ai vraiment regardé le
c'est plus que touchant quoi c'est
bouleversant ça vous change
vraiment votre courage j'étais emporté
là par l'histoire
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu